[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
the Senate
is ours
[ __ ] them we still need to lean into the
race down in Georgia we need to make
sure there's 51 for a lot of different
reasons we're going to go over that
today
also also it's still very close in this
house it does appear that um there it's
going to be one or two seats like I've
been saying one or two seats is going to
decide the house here
um I think there was a race called in
New Mexico that was flipped by democrats
I'm not sure the exact race within the
last hour or two
um so it's going to come down to the
skinny and there's a lot of people still
trying to cure ballots in California so
if your ballots are still outstanding
and they need to be cured you can hear
my voice
go get them cured and follow the
directions
um I know Mueller she wrote Allison Gill
is uh is has been posting on her Twitter
page about curing ballots in California
so it's super important that these races
go our way even if it's just one vote
now I know people are worried about the
Republicans taking the house but here's
the thing even if they take the house by
one maybe two votes they're already
freaking out they can't they won't be
able to develop a leadership that they
want with one or two votes
um it's going to be very difficult for
them to bang up the house now even if
they use the house as a committee wedge
to talk about Hunter Biden's laptop for
the next 24 months well good luck to
them I actually believe that that will
damage them more than it will help them
if if this last midterm that we just had
is more of a sign that America is
[ __ ] sick and tired of these [ __ ]
fascists I don't know what you were
paying attention to and for them to
double down and triple down and
quadruple down on more fascism and more
Insanity more this Q Anon [ __ ] and
really I think that is the the wedge
that is being drawn here that we need to
draw here I said this morning on Twitter
I am not going to [ __ ] give you a
single ounce of attention for what
damage dim leadership wants to be I
don't give a [ __ ] what the dim
leadership is I don't give a [ __ ] don't
care we're not going to pay attention to
that here on the Tony Michaels podcast
here's what we're gonna do we're gonna
we're gonna drive these [ __ ] wedges
between the Maga and the GOP and we're
going to keep doing it we've been doing
it for two years I'm gonna keep doing it
for the next two years
it's an effective [ __ ] strategy it's
what won gen Z and women
absolutely engaged in their democracy
not because Dems had a great a great set
of candidates it's because they didn't
want crazy in charge it's not [ __ ]
complicated this is not [ __ ]
complicated and we got the narrative out
we got the message out and they listened
and they engaged that's what is
important and now that we have a
movement built behind the Democratic
party now it's not the time to change
the narrative it is not the time to
change the messaging you lean into that
[ __ ] we have to draw these
wedges because they're doing it they're
doing it on their own
Rhonda Santos and Trump are fighting
over who is the who is the head [ __ ] of
Maga now all the meanwhile Marjorie
Taylor green is absolutely wanting to go
to Civil War quote shirt quote not mine
her quote civil war with the Republican
Party good [ __ ] him and let's keep let's
keep encouraging it that's why I want
Trump to win run let's do that on
Tuesday that [ __ ] better run and
I hope he wins the nomination you
goddamn right let's do that let's Let
them fight it out and the criminal who
is indicted in several federal courts
gonna be their nominee let's do that
[ __ ]
we secured the Pennsylvania governor it
it appears that the Arizona governor is
going to be Katie Hobbs Whitmer won in
in Michigan
folks those are the three states that
they wanted to steal the election in
2024.
we also kicked out the [ __ ] Secretary
of States in those swing States folks we
are in good shape for 2024 as long as
Georgia comes through for us
rather we have one vote in the house to
keep the majority are they have one or
two votes for them to have the majority
we're in good shape for our democracy
now we are not in shape to [ __ ] to
govern
because we have minority rule in this
country now I'm gonna wait to see what
the count number is
but I can only imagine I can only
imagine when you compare how many seats
are in the house where the Republicans
versus how many [ __ ] votes versus
Democrats what I'm saying is is that the
Democratic house members have way
[ __ ] more votes way [ __ ] more
support way more of a mandate of that's
what this country wants and we have to
lean into that
and how we do that is keep doing what
we've been doing
we absolutely call them out on the rug
we absolutely mock them we absolutely
call out their [ __ ] nonsense like
this morning
um some one of Genie Thomas's
foundations is trying to stop
the the leadership elections in the
house and the Senate [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
get the [ __ ] out of here with that
nonsense
why why would we stop the Senate we know
who's going to take the Senate we know
who the leadership and the Senate is
going to be oh well it would be unfair
to Herschel Walker who gives a rat's ass
[ __ ] didn't get enough votes to
be the senator and there's a runoff so
tough [ __ ] that's how democracy works
you either win or you don't [ __ ] and
you didn't win
so [ __ ] you we should not delay this and
again we should not be fighting over who
leadership is in the pro-democracy party
who gives a rat's ass [ __ ] them let them
do what they want to do what we need to
focus on
is is making sure that this shiv that we
have stuck into this no red wave
we twist that son of a [ __ ]
and we twist it by drawing wedges
between them because they're doing it
they're doing it Beautiful Boards all we
got to do is point it out and encourage
it push them in that direction hell yeah
we want them to fight
this idea that the Democratic party has
been disarray is [ __ ] stupid that's
the dumbest [ __ ] [ __ ] I've ever heard
of in my life
it is very clear that this country is on
the path for democracy that is what they
want that is what they said on the in
the midterm
no clear vote then what was said
democracy democracy democracy
that's what it is
now if the Republicans win the house if
they get it by one maybe two seats
and who gives a [ __ ] who their [ __ ]
leader is really I mean we're gonna
we're gonna draw wedges between them
we're gonna make sure they fight that
out I want them to fight that out oh
yeah [ __ ] let's have a [ __ ] bloodbath
between those [ __ ]
and we're gonna encourage it we're gonna
draw wedges
and we're gonna keep going
keep pushing this narrative because it
worked the country listened
but who gives a [ __ ]
for two long years they're going to talk
about a laptop
and they're gonna try to they're gonna
try to shut down the government
this is gonna be their plan folks
they're not gonna have votes in the
Senate
but they're here's what they're going to
do they're gonna they're gonna try to
shut down government which they are
going to be actively doing it we must
point this out
their party is going to fight them
there's gonna be a there's gonna be a
non-maga faction a non-maga caucus that
is going to fight them every step of the
way in the house because these people
are going to rely
on the non-maga vote to win
there is less and less and less of them
this trumpism [ __ ] is not cool anymore
even in their [ __ ] party it's not
beginning to be not cool
and if that [ __ ] fat slob wins it
will be even more uncool
let him run
let him win the nomination [ __ ] him
let's let's do it again in 2024
to absolutely show these [ __ ]
how we feel about Trump and trumpism
[ __ ] them
let's do it
the Cheeto dusk q and honor has lost his
mind
My Hope Is My Hope Is is that they slow
walk these indictments let him [ __ ]
run let him destroy what is left Amanda
I'm telling you there was never there
was not a national election
since January 6 until this midterm
until this midterm there was not a
national voice
and if if you were paying attention to
this midterm you knew what the national
voice was [ __ ] Trump
[ __ ] him
and if you want to destroy what is left
to Maga I mean you know what whatever
the [ __ ] Republicans decide they want
their leadership to be Beyond Trump well
[ __ ] we'll deal with that later
right now we must draw wedges we must
drive wedges all the way deep down
inside of Manga versus the GOP
and they're already doing it themselves
this is going to be fairly easy right
this is not going to be a difficult
thing to do
especially if you come here and listen
to me every [ __ ] day because that's
what I'm going to be doing
I'm going to be spreading the national
narrative
that manga is still Fascism and manka is
still a danger manga is still a threat
yeah it may not be a threat to the
presidency but it's a threat to your
school boards it's a threat to your
goddamn state legislators
it's a [ __ ] threat
fascism just doesn't die
it'll go hide out underneath the rock
for a little while
but if we don't lean into this if we
don't keep making sure
that manga is Enemy Number One of
democracy
and we spell that out and one National
voice
they won't go anywhere
they won't
it's gonna take a while folks
these people still believe that they can
gain power by cheating and lying
even after even after 2016 when he lost
by three million and he still won on a
technicality after 2018 after 2020
losing the presidency the house and the
Senate
and then and then in this 2022 midterm
can't gain the Senate gave Democrats a
seat
and it appears that it's going to be
almost a virtual [ __ ] tie in the
house
when they expected to pick up 40 60
seats some stupid [ __ ] like that I never
believed they were going to pick up
these many seats I actually still I
still believe that there's a chance of
them can take the house we'll see
we'll see how these votes fall
and again you know we can [ __ ] about
counting and how long it's taking
which you know that's another fight for
another day
now it's the time to fight fight and
beat back manga fascism the America
First Nazis I showed you a clip last
week of Nick Fuentes he's the head of
America First he's he's Marjorie Taylor
Green's good buddy
they always have the America First pack
the AFT pack to rebut the CPAC because
it's just not fascist enough for them
they want it to be full-blown Nazi
Holocaust deniers
Marjorie Taylor green went and spoke to
the this [ __ ] chucklehead supporters
and then when asked about it she's like
well I really think I should uh speak to
those young people you mean the young
Nazis listen I I this is a quote
if there's 10 people sitting at a table
with one Nazi you have 11 Nazis sitting
at a table that's how it works
Todd [ __ ] works and Nick Fuentes is a
goddamn Nazi America First Nazi he's
self-proclaimed America first
and he said in his clip the reason why
they want a dictator is because they
want to [ __ ] tell you what to do
that's why America said in one voice
hell no to trumpism
because enough of them actually got the
message that holy [ __ ]
they want to fundamentally make us a
white National
a white white nationalist Nation
white Christian nationalism is what they
want and they want to force it down your
[ __ ] throat they don't want you to
have contraceptives they don't want you
to have bodily autonomy they won't want
women to vote they don't want young
people to vote they don't want people of
color to vote they don't want it
and Marjorie Taylor green is the head of
that Spear and she's calling for civil
war in the Republican party let's give
it to her
yeah let's give it to her let's do that
let's encourage it Hills to the yeah
let's put them in an arena and let them
let them have a bloodbath
let them slice each other up politically
because I I talked about last week
political capital and why political
Capital was so [ __ ] important that's
why Trump's freaking out
Trump is freaking out because he lost
all his political capital in this
midterm all of it he spent it all on
these [ __ ] stupid candidates
and the reason why he spend it on stupid
candidates is because you have to be a
[ __ ] bonehead to be so loyal to this
[ __ ] idiot and his political message
lies just outright [ __ ] lies queuing
on lies
you have to be a [ __ ] bonehead
to subscribe to that [ __ ]
and he selected them the [ __ ]
boneheads of the boneheads of the
boneheads
and that was his candidates
and he spent every single ounce of
political capital on [ __ ] Q Anon
loyalists
the only one that really won was JD
Vance and he was pretending to be a q
anoner not really a q a honor hell he
called Trump America's Hitler for [ __ ]
sake
so yeah
let's encourage this
let's encourage their little Civil War
they want to have
stand back
and watch them
slice up their party destroy each other
[ __ ] them
that's what they want let them do it
and again I hope tomorrow that Donald
Trump announces he's going to run for
president
and I hope almost immediately the party
has to make decisions whether they're
going to get behind him or they're going
to look
for a new girlfriend
we'll see
we'll see what happens
but we must encourage it
we must encourage the infighting
everyone wants the Department of Justice
to act now
[ __ ] why why they lost they have no
power
what are they gonna do with one vote
what again they're going to talk about
Hunter Biden's laptop for two [ __ ]
years after they just got done bitching
about milk and gas prices and they're
not going to do a [ __ ] thing about
that not a goddamn thing are they going
to do what are they going to hold
[ __ ] Congressional hearings so
Democrats can explain in the
Congressional hearing how what Joe Biden
and the Democrats did to try to help the
inflation problem and and the fuel price
problem
is that what they're gonna do yeah okay
all right that'll work out really
[ __ ] well for them let me tell you
that'll that'll go over fantastic
where the House Republicans what else
they gonna do shut down the [ __ ]
government oh good luck with that
nonsense oh America will be super happy
that they shut down the government you
really think you really think if they
have a one or two vote margin
you really think
do you really believe that they're going
to be able to shut down the government
that there's not going to be a handful
of Republicans to tell them to [ __ ] off
they ran on this and they're gonna be
like let's shut down the government yeah
they're gonna be on TV they're gonna be
on Fox news we're gonna play clip after
clip after clip of them drooling to shut
down the government
you don't think there's gonna be five
ten house members that are Republicans
that are gonna go [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm not
voting for that nonsense I want to win
my race in 2024.
that's why we gotta draw the wedges
that's why we got to keep mocking these
[ __ ]
we gotta keep at it we can't stop just
because there was no Red Wave doesn't
mean that our battle and our fight is
over
I told you this for months
2022 midterm was the most important
election of our democracy's lifetime and
you came through for democracy democracy
won
regardless of how the house plays out
democracy one and the most important
seats that democracy won was those
Secretary of States and those Governor's
races
that was the most important thing for
the 2024 race 4 democracy is you got you
got people who are level-headed who
aren't [ __ ] queuing on us running
States
I mean yeah you had some election
deniers and and and and Q and honors run
in some red States but that shit's gonna
go red anyways they aren't going to be
able to what are they gonna do come up
with fake electors for the Republicans
that are already getting electors it's
really stupid [ __ ]
yeah
so democracy won and you did it you you
the people did it
gen Z women got out and [ __ ] voted
against fascism against authoritarianism
and they won some Races they won some
states they were bound to
but it only gives us it only gives us a
good pulse on where we can win and where
we cannot win and what we can and cannot
do for 2024 and how we can save
democracy again because they're gonna
come for it they're not gonna stop they
want to destroy our country because they
want white Christian nationalism they
are [ __ ] Nazis
and as long as they have just a just an
ounce of power they're gonna try to push
that agenda
and they have a lot of power in media
folks they got loud voices they're the
loudest of the loudest the loudest
[ __ ] that's why I yell and
scream from this microphone every
goddamn day because we must be louder
than they are
we can't just sit back and let them take
our democracy because they like to Yap
about it we must talk we must push the
narrative it is super important
and you're the best audience in the
world you come every single weekday for
two full hours and it's growing and
growing and growing our audience is
getting bigger every day and I believe
for the fight for democracy it's only
going to grow and it's only going to get
bigger because it is clear
it is clear that the people in this
country
give a [ __ ] about democracy they really
do give a [ __ ]
they really do care about what the
makeup of their country is
it's important to them
especially this generation that's coming
up
which we've never seen before young
people are always concerned about the
makeup of their country and their
policies but we've never seen a
generation a Young Generation engage
in the ballot like gen Z did
it's it's it's it's very reassuring
and it's only going to get more and more
and more
for the demographics to lean towards
democracy here
but we cannot take advantage of that we
we cannot we cannot
let down
we cannot back down from the fight
we cannot stop leaning into democracy we
have to keep these conversations going
because trust me if they do get the
house if they do
if this Falls where they've got one or
two votes in the house and they've got a
republican Majority Leader or a
republican speaker whoever the [ __ ] that
may be they're gonna
they're gonna fight it out anyways I
mean we should we should ask for Adam
kinzinger or Liz Cheney that's what we
should be suggesting that's what we
should be trumpeting Adam ginziger or
Liz Cheney they [ __ ] hate those
[ __ ] let's do it and what Liz
Cheney and Adam kinsinger fight that out
with them of course they're not going to
be the speaker but let's do it [ __ ] it
let's draw the wedge
and let's let's make sure they got a
reasonable person and a q an honor on
the ballot and let's let's Hammer that
wedge all the way deep down inside the
GOP and manga [ __ ] them
that's the national narrative
we'll do this we're gonna do this again
I I'm telling you folks there is way
[ __ ] more of us than there are of
them and this election proves it and
we're gonna have more proof of that when
we see how the vote actually falls when
every single vote is counted every
single race is called we will be able to
add up and tally up all the votes for
democracy
versus autocracy and you will see not
just in the governor's races the
Secretary of State races but in the
house and the senate democracy is King
here
this is the [ __ ] shining City on the
hill for democracy
that's what pisses them off
so let's stick together let's keep this
narrative up let's keep driving that
wedge between Maga and GOP let's make
DeSantis and Trump fight this [ __ ] out
make them fight if they win the
speakership make them fight for it with
each other [ __ ] them
don't worry your little head about
Democratic politics because let me tell
you something
Joe Biden is going to be the nominee
stop the nonsense if you're out there
talking about who the [ __ ] is going to
be the Presidential nominee for the Dems
you are you are you are you are helping
the [ __ ] Nazis
trust me when I say this if you are
saying anything are you Tweeting it
writing it [ __ ] talking about it with
your friends about how old he is or
whatever listen to me Joe Biden is going
to be the nominee
he is going to
Joe Biden is going to be the Democratic
nominee there ain't a goddamn thing you
can do about it either so don't even try
it ain't worth it you're just gonna hurt
the pro-democracy coalition
and you may not like it fine whatever
cool I don't care if you don't like that
Joe Biden's gonna be the president going
to be the Presidential nominee for the
Democratic party again I don't give a
[ __ ] neither does Joe Biden but he's
going to be the nominee
that's what's going to happen
regardless of what you want
whether you want him to be the nominee
or don't want him he is going to be the
nominee so just take that fact set it on
the shelf and then go fight fascism
that's what you got to do
that's what you have to do just let them
[ __ ] fight out the Civil War [ __ ]
them
[ __ ] them
everybody I appreciate you being here
every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter twitch make sure you
follow us here on YouTube subscribe to
YouTube also go over to Twitter and
follow us while while it's still live at
Tony Michael's POD at Tony Michaels you
can also follow me at the Tony Michaels
and my co-host Gabe Sanchez and I am
Gabe Sanchez over on Twitter I opened a
mastodon account do you guys know what
Mastodon is I'm still trying to figure
it out over there I posted a few things
this morning I had a few people follow
me and maybe and I'll add it to um
I'll add it to the list here and a lot
of people seem to be going over to
Mastodon I'm not promoting it
necessarily other than I open an account
so if you want to go if you are sick of
Twitter you go over to Mastodon you
check me out there I'm going to try to
post there and Twitter see how it goes
there's a lot of different social media
sites out there that are claiming are
going to be the the replacement for
Twitter but um we'll see how all that
that pans out another favor you can do
for me is go to your favorite podcast
directory and download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
Apple Spotify Google and also leave a
review while you're subscribing on your
favorite directory here's another favor
you can do for me if you're on Facebook
if you still have the books of face and
you still got an account go follow me at
the Tony Michaels we broadcast from the
Midas touch Facebook page but I also
broadcast on my page and I post a few
little cute little memes with some curse
words
that are great wedges to drive between
the GOP and Maga over there on Facebook
so follow me at the Tony Michaels on
Facebook and you you know if you like
the twitch
Style
chat live chat you can go follow us on
Twitch it's a free app I don't get paid
for twitch but it's a free app a lot of
people like the chat over there it's a
little different than YouTube
just the smidge different
we have Rachel bittickoffer Dr Rachel
bittickoffer gonna join us at the top of
the hour so we're going to do a little
bit of [ __ ] list Roundup here I want to
show you a couple videos
of these boneheads infighting of the of
the Maga GOP Civil War
so let's do this let's go to a break
when we come back we'll go to the [ __ ]
let's round up and then Rachel
bidikoffer at the top of the hour
everyone stick around don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
Monday
the new week
how was your guys's weekend
what'd you do over the weekend did you
celebrate when the day when the Dems
took the Senate
huh did you celebrate woohoo everyone
celebrated I had a few people message me
like I can't wait to hear what you have
to say about the Senate we want it
that's what that's what I have to say we
[ __ ] won
when these with these little snowflake
fascists
crying and they're crying
in their Maga tear glasses
it was a glorious weekend that was the
highlight of the weekend
to me it was the highlight
but you know there's democracy and stuff
now what what did you do for your
weekend what how great was it was there
anything that stood out specific other
than that we won the Senate
again
yes that's right we won Trump lost
um say it again and again and again and
again and again and again Trump lost he
lost the Senate folks
that's what happened
those Trump [ __ ] candidates got their
asses handed to him Oz
IL Walker everywhere listen if there
wasn't a runoff election
in Georgia meaning if that wasn't the
thing that happens Herschel Walker would
not be the [ __ ] senator
you got it
if there was not a runoff
in Georgia
Warnock would be the senator today and
we must keep that momentum going in that
race we must we cannot let down on that
race it's going to be up and coming
but really until tomorrow we find out
what the Cheeto desk Q anoner's
announcement is then we can start to
really get a good vision of what wedges
we need to draw on that race now
warnock's doing a great job
and the reason why is because Herschel
Walker is doing such a shitty job I mean
really the bars
it's not high down there for Herschel
Walker
and he's not going to get any help from
Mitch McConnell he's not going to get
any help from Kemp Walker that is
and when you're not getting any help
from Republicans and and here now that
now that the Senate is already secured
by democrats there's probably not going
to be a lot of Ted Cruz and Lindsey
Graham going all the way down to Georgia
for this [ __ ] knucklehead to lose
why why would they do that why would
they spend money and treasure and time
on the Walker seat when they don't want
him in the senate in the first place
that's right they don't want him in the
Senate
this is [ __ ] bone-headed [ __ ] one of
the most excited people in Washington
this morning is Mitch McConnell
you know that right Mitch McConnell's
not sad that Trump lost the Senate he's
not
Mitch McConnell only cares about his own
power
if Trump would have won the Senate Mitch
McConnell would not be the leader nope
not a thing they would have mounted a a
huge campaign against him and put some
kind of [ __ ] Trump senator
in the majority leader position not
McConnell McConnell did not want these
[ __ ] to win
got it and Trump's the one who
who drove that wedge into the party
he drove it and then we kept driving it
right
Blake Masters
Dr Oz Herschel Walker
come on
there was even there was even talk from
these idiots before they knew they'd
lost that they weren't going to vote for
Mitch McConnell to be the leader
Mitch McConnell knew that months ago
[ __ ] months ago that Trump was trying
to take the Senate away from him
why do you think Mitch McConnell moved
around money to murkowski
it wasn't because he loves murkowski or
murkowski some kind of vote for
Democrats
it wasn't it wasn't in favor of the
Democrats it was against Trump
that's the whole point that's the whole
[ __ ] Point here
is that we must let them fight we must
let them Drive wedges or we gotta drive
wedges in between them
and the greatest wedge that was driven
in between him was these [ __ ]
candidates he sent it candidates
and Herschel Walker is the one left out
to dry here I don't know if you've seen
video of him on the campaign Trail over
the weekend but the dude's like whoa
wait a second I didn't expect to keep
campaigning I thought they were just
gonna make me slanted her
and then I was gonna get be the the
senates of the Senate sirs and I was
gonna I was gonna get me in office
at the White House that's probably what
he thinks I don't know he probably
Herschel Walker probably thinks his
office if he's the center is at the
White House right don't you think that
surely I mean he doesn't know that
America is in the United States
which is the greatest country in the
United States
yeah okay
oh [ __ ] this is what you get when you
let Trump pick your [ __ ] candidates
that's why I keep telling you I want him
to run
he is destroying them
absolutely [ __ ] destroying them
and they want him to remain the Maga
King
just just doubt me on this they want him
to remain the ultra Maga King the Cheeto
dust cue in honor as we call him now we
used to call him the Cheeto does mobster
but he's kind of lost his mobster status
he's just not that good at crime they're
going to catch him in all of it
and now he's just full-on so we're gonna
change course and we're gonna call him
the Cheeto dust Cuban honor he's the
king he's the king yeah here kinky kinky
has it here they stole the electron
and they stole Blake Masters electron
out there in Arizona
it's um it's crazy stuff
but we must keep at it we must keep
leaning in we cannot let down
and that is why we're going to continue
to do this shitless Roundup where we
round up all the Tweety tweets and
trendy Trends as long as Twitter is
still alive and Elon hasn't [ __ ]
burned it to the ground so let's get to
the [ __ ] list Roundup start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Roundup where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and training Trends why it still
exists and Elon still is online here
oh my God
what a [ __ ] show over at Twitter I know
you guys don't exactly like all the
Twitter talk but God damn
God damn
he is such a [ __ ] failure I wish some
people were saying that Elon Musk should
buy Fox News next I actually think this
morning I tweeted this I I think you
should buy the RNC
yeah [ __ ] yeah let's let Elon buy the
Republican party let's do that well why
not [ __ ] it he's doing such a marvelous
job at Twitter
oh this [ __ ] guy
he
he's trying to make Twitter better what
he does is fire all the people that can
make the Twitter better
and then he sees that tweeting policy
and any moment's notice he's tweeting
conspiracy theories he's basically
making Twitter a pretty 4chan and 8-chan
it's insane stuff it's crazy stuff but I
got some more crazy for you this morning
because our concentration is going to be
to drive wedges here's Marjorie hooffoot
green
she won her race down in Georgia
there's another thing that we need to uh
make sure to have discussions about is
why we should not [ __ ] stick our
noses and especially our [ __ ]
treasure into races where the Q Anon is
going to win [ __ ] that [ __ ] let them
have the win
let them have the crazy so we can point
it out how [ __ ] crazy they are it's
good for our narrative it's good for
it's good
to bang them up
I'm glad she's going to be in the house
that's right everyone wants her not to
be in the house but look she's gonna say
the same crazy [ __ ] whether she's got a
house seat or she doesn't and what we
can do is tie her to the Republican
party now she's one of them that's right
drive that wedge but let's listen to
what kind of what kind of wedges she's
going to give us here for the GOP Maga
Civil War let's listen and politics is a
blood sport and because it is so
difficult and you have to fight as hard
as possible and Steve you know what
that's like we have to dig in sometimes
and we have to do everything we can to
stop our enemy and the enemy is the
Democrat Party that's the enemy of
America because they are destroying our
country and selling us out and so this
is why our conference has to unify and I
say this Andy Biggs is one of my dearest
friends I love him to death Matt gate
closest Ally somebody I trust all the
time all of these people that are
involved in this challenge are my
friends and if you know Jake Sherman
wants to call it the MTG wing of the
party so be it but I'm also willing to
step out and I know the ground I know
how it works on the inside and the
outside and we have to put someone in
for speaker that is going to be elected
and not allow the Democrat to pull away
one or two because that's what they want
to do and they can do it believe me it
can be done we have Republicans in there
that it would possibly make a deal as
hard as that is for people to believe
there's your wedge folks she's giving it
to you there's your [ __ ] wedge
you want to know the wedge find those
one two three [ __ ] people that are
gonna be turned and wedge that
[ __ ]
that's what's gonna happen you're gonna
have the anti-maga caucus
in the house regardless regardless if
they win or Not Here depending on how
the boats fall if they have one two or
dims have the one seat majority rule
here
then we'll see but they're gonna have a
non-maga caucus now there is going to be
an Insurgency inside the Republican
house
against Trump
and against Marjorie Taylor Greene and
Matt Getz
and we should use them to draw the wedge
and how you do that is you mock both of
them you tie Marjorie Taylor green to
the people who don't want to be tied you
see that so let's say we have a congress
big couple Congress people who at the
Republicans win right let's say we have
a couple of those Congress people
that are gonna vote anti-mtg
Marjorie hooffoot green
vote against the sex trafficker Matt
Getz
and Jim I don't report sex crimes Jordan
they're going to vote against him right
what we do is we tie them to those
people
not not divide them don't say oh these
are really good Republicans oh these
Republicans are good [ __ ] no you're
Republican
you are a goddamn Republican regardless
if you vote against Marjorie who foot
green or not now is a convenient time
not to be a fascist huh that's what we
do we must draw those wedges because
then they have to prove themselves and
the way they prove themselves is they
fight with other Republicans right Gabe
Sanchez that is exactly right were you
not ready or you know no I wasn't no no
okay I was crying I was crying in my
head he's trying to figure out what the
hell I'm talking about no no no have you
seen this have you seen this clip of
Margaret Taylor green I just showed it I
don't think I saw the clip but I saw a
tweet about her complaining I mean like
here's the thing like I wrote it on the
board actually okay let's let's see
let's see there there let's is confused
they do not know who to blame who to
point the finger to you've got Ted Cruz
freaking out and you've got uh you know
you've got obviously Trump who's blaming
other people you've got uh who else is
on the list
um we've got Charlie Kirk
who admitted that the Democrats beat
them even though they said mailing he
was like even though I don't want to do
it we have to push mail-in voting uh uh
even though it's cheating so well here's
here's the thing here's the thing about
that because that's another wedge we can
draw right so when these [ __ ] idiots
start supporting these these these uh
ways to win elections right the way to
drive the vote early voting Mainland
voting apps and t-boning same-day
registration when and ballot curing
where you're where you're launching a
campaign which uh again mentioning that
anybody in California that needs to cure
their ballot go check your ballot and
cure your ballot there's directions uh I
believe Mueller she wrote Allison Gill
in Colorado
Colorado and California what's in
California did I miss something uh well
they're curing ballots there's some cure
in one of the districts someone was
tweeting anywhere you can cure about if
you're a ballot I don't give a [ __ ]
where it's at I mean I gotta say I think
this might be the only election where
I've ever heard Republicans tell their
constituents to cure their ballots well
that might be the first time ever but
but the point I'm making is is now that
they're doing that we don't say yay
you're doing it we say you [ __ ]
pieces of garbage we point it out you
[ __ ] cheating stealing elections
[ __ ] we pointed out we pointed
out because that's what they acute we
put it right back on them we have to we
have to drive these wedges and the best
wedge that I think we can drive is in
the house because the situation is
either going to be that the Democrats
are going to have the one vote one or
two vote majority or the Republicans it
really looks like Republicans are going
to have a one vote majority at this
point they're still balance being
counted though it can still happen right
it's not out of the woods some people
are calling the race
um some aren't at this point because
it's it's just really unclear what the
Count's gonna be but we will get there
in the next few days I'm sure where we
will know what the makeup is going to be
and you already have Genie Thomas in her
organization trying to steal another
election by by
oh it's so unfair to Herschel Walker if
yeah if they vote for [ __ ] him [ __ ] him
he lost that election the reason the
reason why we're having a runoff isn't
because Herschel Walker won it's because
worn off didn't get 50. he won the race
he just that's the reason why I'm right
and also the fact that they have to
identify that I mean the number might be
much higher now but at least on Election
night it was 70 000 people 70 000 voters
looked at that ballot who were
Republican and said yeah I'll vote for
kemp they saw uh Herschel Walker's name
and they stopped and they go
um no no and they either didn't vote
they did not like actually I think
that's most the case right or were they
I mean I think that's the highest
percentage right I mean that's 70 that's
70 000 votes at least on Election night
right there which is they looked at Kemp
as a Republican and said yep that's my
guy or that's my party they looked at
Herschel Walker and they said uh I don't
know who the [ __ ] this guy is or like
and not and not so much who the [ __ ]
this guy is but like why was he even on
the ticket right like why was he even
someone that the Republican Party pushed
and obviously that's because they
completely they they completely hitched
themselves to trumpism and election
denialism
and believing that uh anything that the
Democrats will do which is just hey
we're gonna have a free and fair
election and everyone should have access
mail-in votes should be able to go there
you shouldn't be cut out a line you
shouldn't do this you should be arrested
if you're trying to get someone water
who's waiting hours in line these are
things that you would think hey we
shouldn't have laws against it right we
should have things that promote a a free
and fair election
but
you've also got Republicans like Trump
and other people who double down like
you know what we gotta take away these
rights we gotta remove the access to
this we got to do this we got to do this
you can't be here at this time you can't
do this at this time I can't stress this
enough when the when Gen Z came out and
and droves and voted because they were
taking away people's rights and then the
immediate reaction was oh my God they
came and voted let's take away the right
to vote like that's why they voted
against you you [ __ ] idiots like
we're only giving them more [ __ ] fuel
for the fight a bunch of dummies if
there was anything we learned especially
from Stacy Abrams the last election she
will get people to vote she will find
people she will activate the base she
will engage the voters now
you also again you brought up gen Z gen
Z is a huge Coalition of people that
have been like hey you're why why would
you restrict access here why are you
saying I don't have rights to my own
body why are you doing XYZ and it's that
Z in gen Z that they come for and they
say [ __ ] this noise and and I guarantee
Stacy Abrams is going to [ __ ] rally
the base around this because now that
she's like Well I obviously didn't win
my governor race here I have all of my
all of my focus is going to be on making
sure uh Warnock wins and Walker loses
and I think that's why why she conceded
so quickly and she moved directly to
that race I mean it's possible because I
I really truly believe in the in Stacey
Abrams authenticity for democracy right
like right like I I don't I actually I'm
not in Georgia so I can't say you know
what who should and shouldn't win I
don't think she should run in Georgia
again
um obviously I don't think Beto should
run in Texas again I don't think Chris
should run in Florida ever again
anywhere ever like dude retire and I'll
be obviously the electability is not
quite there now I'm not saying that
those those folks shouldn't still
participate in politics they absolutely
should and I'm not saying that there's
openings later on down the road Beto's a
young guy Chris not so young a Stacy
Abrams definitely could have an opening
later on down the road but right now
it's more important that we get their
energy and and and their fire because
there's one thing to say about Stacey
Abrams like you're saying she can get
out the vote but Ben O'Rourke is the
same [ __ ] way that they drive
democracy right and that is the most
important thing that I think that the
Democratic party needs to lean into is
this idea of your choice of democracy
versus autocracy you choose and I think
that's why gen Z engaged so much because
young people are always political
they're not scared of political opinions
right right they're not scared to voice
um their opinion but they always have
struggled to engage in the ballot and
The Ballot Box they did not struggle
this time right gen Z is very organized
they have a certain way that they
organize because they have a certain way
that they communicate that's why the
[ __ ] polls are wrong we were saying
that for [ __ ] weeks that this these
polls are Antiquated we were saying it
for months that there's polls are
Antiquated there's no way that these
polls were actually telling the truth
right and it came we said we said ignore
the poll exactly just go vote do not
look at the poll and for everyone else
tyt and uh David Pacman who who who
literally were pushing you know hey you
know they they add content to the the
political kind of Stratosphere but when
you've got people on those programs who
are saying well looked at the polls
today and it doesn't look too good for
the Democrats
it annoyed me it annoyed me because
here's the thing like even if you did
know you were like I could see the
future and I know Democrats are going to
lose why would you not why like why
would you not be like hey look we have a
shot here we have a chance everyone
should exercise their right to vote
because here's the thing if you don't
get people to vote in this election what
makes you think you're gonna get people
to vote in the next election right
that's why that's why Manga is on the on
the ropes here don't you I think and
right now you've got many races like
there are there are there are many many
house races that I've that I've been
following where I'm like this is
thousands of votes apart from me it's
close literally every vote counts and so
you need to make sure that like yeah
voting is [ __ ] cool it's great it's
awesome because then at the end of the
day you're gonna say ah you know I voted
and at least I did my part and I had to
say or like oh my one vote actually
contributed to that win right or that
person's loss or whatever it might be
and I look at this and I say if you push
people away and saying there's no point
why would you even Caster ballot because
the polls say they're already going to
lose which we know we're already heavily
leaning right
due to where the polls were coming from
and where the averages were were were
aggregating those polls from and so at
the end of the day it's it's why
wouldn't you get people to go vote why
wouldn't you get people to get engaged
because right again if you don't do it
now then what makes you think because
here's the thing it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy if you say
suppression right
if you say we're not going to win
another person what's the point avoiding
what's what's the point of voting right
and then and then at that point you
don't vote and then that candidate does
lose meaning the Democratic candidate
loses and the Republican wins and they
go well see there was no point in me
voting because they were already going
to win so the next election that person
says well what's the point I didn't vote
the last time and my candidate didn't
win so what's one vote gonna do well if
you're [ __ ] in Colorado District
three and you're against Lauren bobert
yeah they've already uh Frisch's
campaign have already cured 200 ballots
which means now I think I think they had
like 1200 that they could write so now
it's down to about a thousand to nine
hundred something that they've already
fixed to say oh the margin's even slower
or shorter and smaller and now but that
goes to show you that when Democrats
engage in action in actual democracy
curing ballots and Republicans don't
that could be the [ __ ] difference
only because we engage we engage in
democracy they hate it they [ __ ] hate
democracy that's what Charlie Kirk's
trying to say speaking of hating
democracy have you seen this clip of
this [ __ ] um Governor's [ __ ] I think
Governor [ __ ] I'm in Oklahoma now we won
his re-election um it was it was uh it
was a nail biter though no no Democrat I
think has ever gained that many votes uh
in a long time in Oklahoma but listen to
what this guy says he's standing there
with his wife listen to this nonsense
this guy's talking about uh I tweeted
white Isis claims Oklahoma I'm not
[ __ ] you listening this father we
just claim Oklahoma for you every square
inch
Jesus father we can do nothing apart
from you yes
principalities and darkness and father
we just come against that we just lose
your will over our state right now
we just thank you that we claim Oklahoma
for you
The Authority that I have is governor
and the Spiritual Authority and the
physical Authority that you give me I
claim Oklahoma for you that we will be a
light to our country and to the world
right here our state we thank you that
your will is gone on Tuesday and father
that you will do have your way with our
state with our education system with
everything within the uh the the walls
behind me and the rooms behind me Lord
that you will root out corruption you'll
bring the right people into this
building father from now on
there you have it the Governor of
Oklahoma the Republican America First
Nazi of Oklahoma
laying claim laying Jesus's in his white
nationalist white Christian nationalists
claim to Oklahoma it's [ __ ] gross and
let me tell you something let me tell
you something and over the next two
years we are really the next four in
Oklahoma we are going to point out every
time that [ __ ] moves every time
he moves in the direction of white
Christian nationalism in Oklahoma
because I would bet that Oklahomans at
the end of the day are not going to put
up with that [ __ ] in the long run this
is this is complete complete
miscalculation by Maga and these white
Christian nationalists that they are
going to that they are going to do what
they wanted to do nationally to these
states I believe it's a big mistake and
I think we should we should lean in and
draw that wedge in the I mean if
anything like it's just for anyone who's
like I'm a constitutionalist or I'm a
constitutional fundamentalist or
whatever the [ __ ] you want to play
got my constitution in my pocket you
some [ __ ] but these are the same people
like oh thank God God is going to be the
one that decides the vote you know uh
thank I'm gonna I'm doing this for Jesus
like okay I think he literally said
Jesus come in Oklahoma right right Jesus
come and don't go home so you're gonna
tell me that the people that have their
pocketbook Constitution that only know
two amendments and they want to [ __ ]
and moan about other things are the ones
that are invoking God's name in Jesus
name and they want to say oh thank God
thank Jesus we're bringing Jesus to you
they're one projecting pushing their own
religion onto you but again the
separation of church and state like are
we just going to ignore the Constitution
that you say that you live and die by
are you going to say that what the
founding fathers that you believe
intended for the Second Amendment
is something don't put words in my mouth
or or on my pocket Constitution here's
another wedge being drawn between him Al
Sparks is great at drawing wedges as
well
um this is actually a post of uh
telegram uh you know you remember
Lynnwood you remember that crazy he's
nuttier than a [ __ ] squirrel turd but
he is he is connected I mean he was
connected down in Georgia last time he
literally said don't vote right he told
people nothing about it he helped us win
our our two seats in Georgia and he made
it this time too and that's the way also
tied to writtenhouse like everything
everything is connected in this group of
like uh right-wing fascism right well so
uh Hal points this out Linwood just
posted this on telegram he he just
dropped the picture of trump being
defeated on telegram like this guy was
the most loyal of the Loyalists like he
was talking about some crazy ass white
Christian nationalist stuff like Linwood
was going to [ __ ] nursing homes and
retirement homes and saying crazy ass
[ __ ] into microphones and then him and
Mike Flynn and Roger Stone they all kind
of got into a [ __ ] fight and they all
started dropping information on each
other because one of which one of which
was the email that was from Tucker
Carlson asking Hunter Biden hey can you
write a letter recommendation for my son
Buckley
to Georgetown right and Hunter said yeah
sure I'll do it wrote the letter and
Tucker goes thanks so much for that
letter man really means a lot I couldn't
have done it without you meanwhile then
Tucker Carlson about a year later
you know it was on the laptop the
[ __ ] email he wrote [ __ ] boom head
well that's the other point that I want
to make here is these wedges that we're
going to draw even if the Republicans
win this house even if they win the
house and they and they [ __ ] fight it
out to this to decide who's gonna be the
stupidest [ __ ] the stupidest [ __ ]
speaker of the house that we've ever had
you think Paul Ryan is a dumb
[ __ ] just wait until they win
the house and they nominate I mean even
if it's Kevin McCarthy we're we're
poised to have this dumbest [ __ ]
speaker
but even if he doesn't get it they're
gonna they're gonna put in an even
dumber [ __ ] yeah you've got uh
Margie Taylor green saying she wants to
beat right didn't she say she wanted to
be the speaker of the house right oh wow
I mean
I almost or she she wants to be this
beautiful house and then Jordan Matt
gets any of them there's also Whispers
of Liz Cheney well we should drive that
wedge she's not going to be this
beautiful house but we should definitely
see like if there was ever a list there
was ever a person where you're like hey
look uh we need to remove the crazy
right Republican right let's call it out
uh it would be that person uh Liz Cheney
to drive a wedge between them to be like
all right I'm gonna be the deciding
factor if we hold the majority in the
house I'm gonna be the person that tells
you when to shut the [ __ ] up because
you're all [ __ ] crazy well I mean as
as long as we're talking driving wedges
I'm not even opposed to us us as a
pro-democracy to say yeah let's do Paul
Ryan again that's cool I mean that'll
really [ __ ] piss him off
it'll it'll it'll really piss them off
when you realize that Paul Ryan and uh
well what he's what he how he was Pro
um uh katanji uh for for Supreme Court
right right and that one that one kind
of blew everyone though oh whoa whoa
because obviously they have a familial
relation and he's like yeah she's great
she's smart she does deserve this
position so to have that in the house
for those people who are very obviously
racist and anti you know what is a woman
and all that [ __ ]
uh you know I don't know what a woman is
they wrote a book they got a documentary
I'll tell you what I've got I I got
someone here that is going to tell us
exactly exactly what is going to happen
exactly what our strategies should be to
keep driving these wedges between manga
and the GOP when we come back we have Dr
Rachel bittickoffer with us to talk
about the midterms break it down Boris
I'm excited to have the doc back on the
Tony Michaels podcast everyone stick
around right after this we have Dr
Rachel bidikoffer
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product part in blanketing I've
got you covered part in blanket
specifically Works to make you feel safe
and cozy after your involvement on
January 6th and if you're one of the
other members of Congress who also
helped with the attempted coup hard and
blanket will protect you too pardon
blanket is made of a sort of soft fleece
and a layer of sheep's wool and they're
a hundred percent made in the USA don't
delay and get your pardon blanket today
for just 99.99 actual pardons not
guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show you
know I was just thinking through that
break with the pardon blanket with a
list of insurrectionists if Lauren
bobert loses her race maybe we should
campaign for her to be the speaker of
the house oh my God how great would it
be for Democrats and democracy for that
bonehead to be in charge of the
Republican caucus in the house nothing
would be better I want to welcome Dr
Rachel bittickoffer oh here we go I'm
seeing I'm I'm lazy here look at this I
got this Banner going on there we go doc
how are you hahaha
I am fan [ __ ] time
fantastic guys how are you welcome
welcome back tell us why you're
fantastic tell us what is exciting you
today this morning
whooping Republican ass dude makes me
happy makes me feel good
so so what what because I I know we
talked a lot through this midterm and we
even talked back in January or February
and we were like hey we need to get a
message out we need to get a national
narrative where it is go vote against
fascism you have a choice democracy or
autocracy and you must decide and we
even use the phrase and you kind of
coined it here on the Tony Michaels
podcast
strategic outrage and to point that
outrage at them right and to make sure
that we're drawing wedges and make sure
we we dictate and we have a narrative of
who they are
did we do that successfully in this
midterm
yes we did or we wouldn't be sitting
here right now right
um you know people are gonna laugh at 5
38 and need silver and Dave Wasserman
all they want and uh you know we can
talk about whether they should have been
using polls after a few elections where
they were problematic but at the end of
the day guys the midterm effect is a
real thing it should have swept
Republicans into power it should have
washed out the blue state governorships
in the Midwest and left us vulnerable to
even having another democratic election
in 2024 and to avoid that fate it took a
lot of strategic lift and you know a
little a sister and Justice Alito
because once we were talking we were
starting to tell people hey there's a
threat to your freedom they proved it by
eviscerating women's fundamental Liberty
right and and we're really I mean we've
got helped along with in two two points
and I think the second one I mean the
first one and the most important is
Alito and the road reversal because that
solved the enthusiasm deficit that we
had and I have argued for a long time
that enthusiasm is the main driver of
midterm effects and now I think I can
prove it right because we equalized it
and we ended up you know it for
Democrats it's a huge [ __ ] Victory
and even if we lose the house it is a
major a major win right so um and then
the second event that happened is you
know we had spent two months running ads
and framing Republicans where we could
where candidates were willing to run the
right race
um you know as an existential threat to
your freedom and to your life right and
what do they do well Paul Pelosi gets
attacked when one of their Mega nuts
gets riled up and and breaks into his
house with a hammer to kidnap and maybe
torture the speaker of the house right
and and that I mean that number one
proves what we're arguing that this is a
movement that's dangerous and is
embracing political violence but the
best thing is that they they come out of
that event and they're laughing they
were laughing all right so here we were
telling people you cannot put these
people in power they are dangerous and
they proved it for us the week before
the election so I'm really grateful that
Republicans
um did so I think it was important that
we got Americans to see what the threat
was before the threat really got here
and it became um unavoidable and you
know to be sitting where we are today
but I I can't be [ __ ] happier
well you know I think you make all those
great points about what the events
leading up to it was but it it's it's so
reassuring that we had an a generation
gen Z and and we knew women would pay
attention we knew that would be that
they would pay attention to this and
they would make sure to to turn out that
boat but it actually gave me like a lot
of pause I thought gen Z would show up
but not even close to what they they
managed to do and it and and again the
Republicans immediately just like the
Paul Pelosi or the Roe um decision they
were like as soon as they knew gen Z
pushed a lot of these races over time to
like take away their vote like that's
exactly why they voted against you you
dummies like they're they're not gonna
learn they're not going to learn and and
I guess my question is rather the the
Republicans win the house or not because
really I think the most important seats
that we won for democracy and especially
for the 2024 race is Pennsylvania the
governor
um Michigan and Arizona Ona and those
speaker of the houses those three states
those those four those four races in
those states were more important than
the House of Representatives right and
and absolutely always my most important
races Tony and you know I I didn't like
say on Twitter hey guess what if
Republicans win Wisconsin governor just
that one Siege they can completely
prevent us from winning in 2024. it's
not like I was gonna tell them that
right because then they would focus on
their fire but on the you know off off
the record and then back channels you
know I kept pushing as much attention
possibly to the Midwest as I could
making it very clear to principals that
are involved in making start smart
decisions you know it you know worst
case we have to expect a midterm effect
to happen it's happened every time in 50
years except for twice when the natural
climate change the the you know focus of
the election what we had to do was try
to make that natural climate like you
know we had to affect the climate
intentionally strategically and like I
said Roe really made a big difference
with that
um without it I don't know that the
strategy would have had as much success
but I know where it would have been
successful and it would have been in the
midwest because if any state especially
ran a pure negative partisanship
strategy from all of their Statewide all
the way down to flipping both chambers
of the state house and uh it'd be the
state of Michigan Right really
demonstrating
um the power of good strategy because I
think even if we hadn't had roe we might
have been able to pull out that but
Wisconsin was just as critical and you
know I couldn't I can't I could not tell
people before the election you may wake
up and the game is done like the whole
[ __ ] enchilada is on 22 and this
midterm effect thing means we're
destined to lose control of Wisconsin
right so um you know one of the reasons
I'm in such a great mood is not only did
we hit those benchmarks those crit
critical democracy saving benchmarks we
actually did much much better than that
and were able to give them more of like
a partisan ass whooping as well but in
terms of the house I may well be the
only Democrat in America who is agnostic
on house control I you know if we
control the house nice because then we
can say we we three swept them in a
midterm event which is unfucking
precedented right and embarrassing as
[ __ ] for the Republican Party
um but either way one or two seat
majority or one or two seat minority
they're a party that is completely
[ __ ] right now and they have no good
move to me and yeah honestly if they are
in control of the house then is going to
put on on real display how [ __ ] up and
and uh disjointed and crazy those people
are for two years so I have said to
people the easiest way to re-elect Joe
Biden is Republican control of the house
with a two-seater majority right the
other the other thing too that me and
Gabe have been talking about on that
point is that if if they do get a one or
two seat they they will develop a
non-maga uh Cox inside their their group
right and and what that will do is it
will give us the ability pro-democracy
people to draw wedges between those
because we get to say because we don't
get to say oh those Republicans are
great that's not what we say we say
you're them too you're just trying to
run away from what you are right and
that will draw that wedge for 2024 and I
know we have a few races in 2023
um and which we should draw wedges there
too but the most important race coming
is 2024 and I even tweeted this morning
that we should not we should not worry
about Democratic Leadership Joe Biden is
going to be the [ __ ] nominee it
didn't it doesn't matter what you do and
we should not we should not worry about
what the dim leadership is going to be
we should worry about drawing wedges and
creating the manga GOP Civil War because
that will be what will be greatest for
for democracy it is obvious that they
are not they are not well equipped to
fight an election where they are on the
defense they just are not that's exactly
that's the first time we've ever put
them on defense and they fell apart dude
right yeah I mean like
no I was going to say the uh the
performance that we've had in the
midterms has been obviously out really
amazingly impressive right like every
single secretary of state that these
deniers that would have had a play in
terms of determining whether to uh
certify and say yep that's the winner
you know or any of these people who
would have had a hand in in manipulating
the outcome of denying the outcome of
the election
um
were were rejected just like outright
which is great I mean some of these
races were close but thankfully
democracy did play a part and they said
no but to your point Tony you talked
about people who are trying to run away
right you've got Josh Hawley over the
weekend being like Oh you know I think
it was when the results came out of
Nevada might have been uh where he would
I forget which race rebuild the party he
was like we've got to come you gotta
tear it down we got to rebuild a backup
from scratch I'm like you were at the
okay one you're running away from Maga
like you did on January 6. you riled
them up on January 6th you riled them up
before the election and now you don't
like the mess that you made because the
mess that you made actually didn't turn
out to be the [ __ ] Masterpiece you
thought it would be and now you're
running away and everyone in that party
they're gonna have a hard time figuring
out who's going to be the leader
because even if they do have a speaker
there's going to be infighting that
continues to go on because they do not
have the majority to say cool I can whip
these votes I know exactly how we're
going to go they're going to have a slim
majority and even with that again like
to what you said Rachel is we're gonna
we're gonna see this on display a party
when you see a senate that pushes these
bills for when you see a house that
pushes these bills forward you're going
to see that the only party that is
stopping it from actually happening is
going to be Republican I mean we also
luckily had two months or so of these
bills chips act infrastructure uh price
gouging all of these things that would
benefit us As Americans push forward by
Democrats and Republicans go like not
really my cup of tea and then he went
and passed out the checks when they did
it exactly the other the other key thing
here that I think
um we're forgetting is that there is way
more of us for democracy than there are
of them and it is never more clear than
in the vote either to reject or to keep
depending on which state it was for
those referendums for bodily autonomy
for women even in Kentucky Kansas
Kentucky they were like [ __ ] keep
your hands off my rights [ __ ]
and even this weird situation where
people were willing to go vote for the
party that wants to take away the rights
but they definitely say no you're not
going to take away my rights it only
because we talk about it before Rachel
where people just don't have
um the Civic wherewithal right they're
not really sure how this stuff works in
Missouri the same way Missouri voted for
recreational marijuana and they voted
for a United States senator who is the
attorney general who is he was the who
is the least
pro-marijuana Recreation that there is
they didn't it never happens when you
don't [ __ ] wedge your policy and make
it clear you know if you want 15 minimum
wage that's a democratic policy
Republicans oppose it it popped
Democratic policy Republicans oppose it
and there's still tons of messaging
shift to do but I have to have to say
made a lot of progress on especially in
the Grassroots getting people to
understand you have to partisan your
policy you've made it super [ __ ]
popular okay so now it's time to add
Republican we'll take away or prevent
you from having this into these messages
but it is a crying [ __ ] shame Tony I
mean because like I would never let
somebody vote for pot and not recognize
that they have to vote for the Democrat
to make it happen right and I do hope
that we can we can you know transition
some of that messaging better for for
going forward
just on this topic okay the Republican
party is as as games pointing out on his
board today and I guess he must write
backwards or he has some cool camera
flip because I can read it says Maggie
is confused okay it is it is a it right
now the Mitch McConnell wing of the
party is [ __ ] their pants they this
is the Democratic accountability small
the Democratic accountability that we
needed since 2016 to shove a wedge into
the Republican party and cause a massive
Civil War the rest of the Civil War the
actual hot part of the Civil War right
right and um it's because they're
confused on defense Unsure how to
proceed probably incapable of proceeding
in the house even if they get the
majority I want to urge everybody
[ __ ] hit them harder let's just keep
punching them right now is when we want
to go on the internet right so like
they're bruised and bleeding let's go
rip their legs off
and make sure they can't get back up
I mean I think a big I think a big push
also is going to you got the GOP that is
is trying to object to Biden's student
loan forgiveness program which obviously
would help even people within the
Republican party and if you know I I
think that's going to be a huge a huge
uh messaging point to be like look we
are trying to help you in a time that is
very hard if you've got inflation you're
trying to you know uh uh pay for this or
cover your family imagine what you could
do if you had that money not going to
pay these loans and I think that'll be a
huge thing because it also shows on
display the Republican Party trying to
stop
President Biden and the Republican party
from actually helping you right from
helping because again I guarantee many
many people within the Republican Party
who vote Republican who would actually
greatly benefit like from this as well
as other social programs that Democrats
try to push but I think that's going to
be a huge one because that was one of
those items that he ran on in uh in the
2020 election talking about canceling
student loans and he delivered on that
as well as other things and the only
people that are stopping that that goal
from actually being achieved is the
Republican party and so it just you know
again it to your point it just shows it
puts them on display of how they are
failing America and in their
constituents
yeah I mean we don't have a system that
does a good job of of highlighting their
activities when they're not in power so
you know I mean there's only so much one
person can do right
or like you know ah we can yell and
scream into a microphone for a few hours
a day if they're if they own
build a house and who will be
will may not be Kevin Carter
Carter said it wouldn't be but
um even if it is I mean I want him to be
speaker because I want him to have to do
it I want him to get his dream job and
have to do it but just like Elon has
failed Twitter
display for two years and the American
public won't forget that the this is a
verb this is this is not a Republican
party it's a republican cult and it is
not capable of government
governing I think you're I think I think
you're right and um if the if the dims
do take the house and we have speaker
Pelosi because that is what will happen
um I believe
um because we only have a one when you
only have a one vote majority you're
gonna have to have someone who really
understands the ins and outs of the
house yes
right there's there's no one's finders
right
when you have 219 and you need 218 to
get leadership position well and I think
that's that's one reason why if the Dems
do pull this out and there is a one vote
um Democratic majority in the house it
will be Nancy Pelosi as a speaker
because they will recognize that they
need someone that understands the house
and the process of the house better than
anyone else and she probably is the one
person in the country above anyone
Democrat Republican that understand the
process and the mechanisms of the house
better than anyone
um so I think we're gonna have if we do
have that one seat in the House Majority
it will be speaker Pelosi again which
will drive them [ __ ] nuts which makes
me even more excited
um you know driving them crazy is
exactly what we need and the reason why
is because like you said earlier they
can't spot the problem right they're
trying to figure out is it DeSantis is
it Trump who's the speaker and they
can't spot the problem that the reason
why you're having this trouble is
because you're you embraced
authoritarianism and you Embrace fascism
so they're not everyone's like oh are
they going to dump Trump now and dump
fascism nope they don't even recognize
that they want to they want to Tony
that's the thing is for the first I mean
they've always wanted to right right the
first this is the first time they well
second because they chose to let the
ship sail after Jan six this is the
second time that they've had the
opportunity right and then in this case
they've been able to tell themselves
there's no electoral price to what's
happened with the Republican party into
letting Trump take it over and turn it
into Maga but now they've paid a price
they should have [ __ ] won 50 seats in
this midterm there is at the only reason
they didn't is because they have turned
their party over to a nut job and turned
it into a cult and not a political party
otherwise they'd be they would have
cleaned up dude they would have [ __ ]
cleaned up if it was a sane party
because that's how midterm effects work
so you know like I said when your
opposition is scrambling when you when
you've won a few battles against them
and really put them in the defensive
posture and they're confused that's when
you add more fire any more heat and you
press your advantage even harder and
that's why I really want people to
understand we should be begging begging
not hoping not dreaming not even
agreeing [ __ ] begging Joe Biden to
run for reelection and I was just
talking about this on Twitter because
I'm always trying to find a way to
convey complex strategy in a simple
[ __ ] way so I showed a picture of a
mountain a very steep Mountain okay and
I said look if I told you you could
start climbing this mountain from
halfway up you would immediately see the
advantage in that okay same thing with
presidential incumbency it's a massive
structural Advantage for us it prevents
us from having a nasty expensive Party
primary process which of anything like
2020 will be a total [ __ ] show and our
media system will always cover our [ __ ]
show more than theirs right and B it
says so it says all that infrastructure
and investment and you can start tealing
it right towards your general election
strategy and uh you know be the
incumbency advantage in the presidency
is still quite powerful you get the
bully pulpit you get agenda setting
power out of that you get the plane to
fly around you already have the job you
get the Pomp and Circumstance played
wherever you go only I would never have
to convince Republicans in other words
not to give up the Strategic advantage
that incumbent re-election presidents
will campaign would present to us over
well I just want something young I just
want time I just think it's time for
change or new leadership okay that you
can have those feelings and I'm not
saying they're not pertinent but
democracy is still [ __ ] on fire and
if we want to kill them kill the fascist
movement and mag off it's going to have
to extend to the next election cycle why
in the hell would we give up our best
strategic Advantage going in I say that
would be stupid and I hope other people
can agree with me on that
I agree I agree wholeheartedly and I
think anyone out there
um you know having this notion that
somehow I mean I don't see how Joe Biden
isn't going to run and I don't see how
anyone would mount a campaign against
him at this point just no no just just
on his record just on his record alone
there's no way that you could you could
really go into a primary and point to
Joe Biden of how he hasn't done more for
Americans than than I got to tell you
Tony if a Democrat was dumb enough to
challenge Joe Biden for the nomination
if he decided to run that's it I'm
[ __ ] out of this country I'm moving
you okay
it should go they should go join Maga if
they're gonna do that because you're you
just don't understand if you're that
[ __ ] dumb that you can't understand
not to challenge your incumbent
president in a in a primary election
after we just took you to the best
historic midterm in the [ __ ] history
of the party then yeah I mean I got
nothing for you dude but also also like
oh yeah
I'm not worried about the Insiders and
establishment in DC in the Beltway
getting this I'm worried about public
sentiment and I want right to give
people food for thought I'm not trying
to tell you what to think I'm just
giving you a different frame to think
about presidential nominations and and
really see the structural disadvantage
we would be at if we push for a
different nominee
mm-hmm
yeah I mean I I completely agree I mean
yeah obviously working at a disadvantage
the other thing too is like if you have
those first four years and if you have
the especially I mean like if you
compare it to the first four years of
Obama versus the second four years which
you know obviously if you have you lose
control of the house or Senate then you
become more or less a lame duck
president where you're trying to do
things but then you've got people like
Mitch McConnell rewriting laws and rules
that you follow in terms of how you
choose a supreme court nominee right and
then when you've got uh if you do in
fact get a a second term where you do
have actual majority and you do have the
power to push past or push through a
legislation that puts your party at a
good Advantage for the following the
following election right not the second
term but the new uh
candidate who is running right obviously
you're starting from scratch Republican
versus Democrat but you already have
eight years to say look at what we did
with our party we didn't have anyone
that was pushing against us and even
when we did have people that were
challenging us from the Republican side
we were able to push forward legislation
and each time we did these things they
said no no no no no no and we pushed
through and we got them through to
actually provide you with stimulus to
provide you a to provide you
infrastructure provide you you know
student loan cancellation provide you uh
recreational or decriminalized marijuana
like all of these things that would
greatly benefit their constituents you
now have that you know kind of Arsenal
to say look at what we did when we did
have control right look at how these
social programs actually benefited
everyone as opposed to Republicans who
say we're going to keep the foot on you
and you can't get out of this well the
the other narrative that you have is
this is if we if we go into fighting in
2024 and we win that election now you
have the political Capital to go into
2026 to win another midterm and that
would only heighten because they're
going to fight this out right Rachel
they're going to battle this out not
just this year but in 2024 2026 this
Maga movement isn't going anywhere
anytime fast they're gonna stick around
because they have control of these
little pockets of the country and
there's nothing we can do about that
they're going to control some power in
some form in this country and it's not
it's going to make them still stick
around so we must have them fighting
each other for 2024 we must have them
finding each other for 2026 and for the
next presidential election after that
and the only way we do that is to keep
driving those wedges and pointing out
how [ __ ] crazy they are and that if
you have crazy people in your party
you're all [ __ ] nuts like that you
are all [ __ ] crazy for even letting
these people inside your party and
that's what we have to we have to pen
manga on them regardless if they want to
run away from it like Josh Hawley ran
away from from him rallying up the
supporters on January 6th
and I got to tell you that runaway is
going to be a lot harder if they hold
that that house majority a lot harder so
if people are really putting a lot of
basket you know fruit into the basket of
winning this majority right now I think
it's like 70 30 probably go into them
but we we've seen Orange County ballots
the the vote by mail system out west it
just takes time and we don't know what's
going to happen with the house but like
you know hopefully now that you've heard
my voice and explain like the Strategic
advantages that will come with that you
know it'd be it will be a lot harder for
us to keep the focus on Maga crazy
though I think indictments are coming
and I think that's going to help
um that if we control the house now I
want to control the house like everybody
else I'm just willing to see the
Strategic advantage of not controlling
it as well well I appreciate you joining
us Doc and again come back next week if
you can and give us more of an update
when we see more of these races fall and
if the Republicans do take the house my
bet is that the word laptop Works its
way into the official record at least 2
000 times in the first 60 days of them
controlling it because they're crazy and
we should pin that on them thank you Dr
Rachel bittickoffer everyone go follow
doc on Twitter why Twitter still exists
um doc give them your give them your
handle there while Twitter still exists
there
not just at Rachel medical for I'll
leave Twitter when they kick me off or
the lights go out and I don't think
either thing will happen I think it's
like no I I'm really excited that so
many people stuck with Twitter and uh
didn't just go and pull the plug right
right before election day because that
would have been a strategic disaster for
the left so
well everyone go follow Rachel and
you'll find the messaging there on her
Twitter page for sure Dr Rachel
whittakoffer thanks for joining us as
always my friend come back again come
back we'll find a day next week that
you're available that we can get some
more updates as these races close and we
know these counts and we know what that
house is going to look like we'll have a
little more how to drive these wedges
I'd love to come back after we get this
Clean Sweep in Arizona and talk about
that story yeah
and how we what the [ __ ] Arizona
gop's ass well let's do that next week
we'll talk about the house what the
outcome is and we'll talk about Arizona
next week thank you Roger right Dr
Rachel bidikoffer everyone stick around
we'll be right back right after these
messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 Seconds
Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign
this is the Tony Michaels podcast
Gabe Sanchez is always like 12 steps
ahead of the of the curve here with that
commercial the the Maga Babble I got a I
got a video I want to show you yep
Sanchez yeah of a teacher in um I don't
know where this is at
but he's talking about how he thinks
he's uh Superior because of his race too
um
black black children in a school
um I don't know if this guy is uh fired
yet but
I I'm not saying he's [ __ ] is this is
this an early moment of [ __ ] around and
find out like are we are we seeing the
what is this guy's name I'm you know
what this is yeah let's see
um this is a Jewish Ginger resistor here
hand it it's both Middle School
um I'm not sure exactly where it is I
even have to finish the whole name I
just said Bo and it was Bulls uh uh
investigated one day ago 20 oh hold on
okay okay all right let me let me pull
this article
uh flugerville flugerville teacher yeah
that's Pflugerville this sounds like a
Dr Seuss book already I know well the
flukers in flugerville fluger the fluger
I don't know the flugerville ISD teacher
accused parents of making racist
comments during ISD what is that it's
like in school detention
uh that is what is the size d
foreign
I don't know what ISD is maybe there's
some teachers in the chat that can tell
us what I I mean it was all ISS when I
was in school in school suspension but
maybe it's in school detention so this
is this is the guy who gets the the
um I'm assuming it's
it's probably something like School
District uh really oh yeah I don't know
oh Independent School District
Independence no Pflugerville Independent
School District teacher Accused by
parents of making racist comments during
a conversation with students accused
he's not accused he's on video saying it
[ __ ] accused so then we go through the
letter states that the teacher is no
longer employed by the district after
the inappropriate conversation as of
Monday morning so he did [ __ ] around and
he found out here's the guy here's the
guy on the screen and I'm gonna play the
video here and but I I want to say
before
it's like a video like this just clearly
demonstrates
why gen Z is like [ __ ] these people [ __ ]
you old white men like are you yeah it's
like why are we surprised that the
people who you know these older people
are these racist people these people who
want to like suppress your Vote or take
away your rights again like we talked
about earlier but God forbid that this
person says no I'm not going to take
this [ __ ] anymore I'm going to do what
I'm going to tell my parents I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do that and then yeah
it's like yeah you [ __ ] talk down to
kids and tell them that tell them
something racist what state is this in
what state is it it's in Texas okay
beautiful Texas even better so this is a
this is the clip and he's in the
classroom and these kids are like
laughing at him right and the reason why
they're laughing at him is because I
would imagine most of them are like we
know who you voted for we know who you
are we know why you are the way you are
and we're gonna get the power to go
against you soon these kids aren't dumb
to this idea that's why gen Z that's why
the [ __ ] polls were off that's why
they're they're Antiquated they either
need to stop doing polls or figure out a
different way to do them because they're
skipping an entire demographic yeah
you were you know 16 when the pandemic
went down and they had Tick Tock as a
way to
to communicate to get the word out to
talk such a good point you remember the
picture we showed that Lynn wood that is
from him when he came back from Tulsa
when the tick tockers absolutely torched
that rally they they gen Z has been
[ __ ] with Trump since 2020. like
since they they've been able to uh to
Corral around and use a technology and
resource and say you know what we're
gonna I mean I had people during that
time that were saying hey make sure to
buy these tickets here make sure to do
this make sure that you know do yeah you
would go on and you would reserve a spot
or whatever right exactly it would look
like they had these big inflamed and
when you show up you're like oh there's
like
20 people and the stadiums for thousands
right there's tens of people because
what because what would happen which
also drove the whole like let's let's
ban Tick Tock that was a big push it
wasn't really security it was more now
now it kind of is yeah but also at the
time was like I'm being humiliated by
these kids these [ __ ] I would have
gotten away with those of you meddling
kids well you know the other thing that
it did is
um it caused him to have to do these
rallies and pastures and the one reason
why is because he can't afford because
he owes so many people [ __ ] money but
the other reason why is because then
they could control it they could control
how big it was because it was it they
had a massive amount of room if a lot of
people showed up because what was also
happening is they would Reserve all
these seats right and it would appear
that they had all this [ __ ] these
people gonna come so they would have to
change venues to be a bigger venue which
made that [ __ ] venue look even more
empty and and gen Z was like you know
run [ __ ] Victory laps that they were
able to use the internet just to [ __ ]
with him but here is here's here's one
of a grandpa q and honor supporters and
you don't have to believe me uh just
listen to his own words he doesn't say
he's a trump supporter but you tell me
he's not and I'll tell you to [ __ ] off
but watch these kids laugh at him when
he gives him his views listen this is
this is this is actually kind of
hilarious
literally they are laughing at him when
he said I'm that's no Centric which
means that my race is superior right and
these kids are like uh you know [ __ ]
no it isn't like they they're laughing
at him it's not that they're angry
anymore these people aren't like the Gen
Z aren't even anger anymore they are
[ __ ] laughing at you white Christian
nationalists they are laughing at you
you are a joke and that's why they're
coming and voting against you not
because they hate you it's because
you're so [ __ ] stupid they do not
want you in control of anything that's
the point also you know if you look at
especially I think the pandemic was a
very interesting developing period for
people right A lot of people you know
especially within labor decide it made
unions stronger don't you think and they
were like hey look my own value and my
self-worth is not worth the amount that
I'm being paid or the hours that have
been worked or or just the type of just
treatment that I'm I'm going through I
believe I deserve more so those people
said [ __ ] it I'm leaving and why a lot
of people like Hey we're hiring we're
hiring
because people were leaving those
businesses right and obviously those
businesses want to say well it's all
because of Joe Biden in the pandemic you
know and it's like that's actually not
why it's because you're a shitty boss
you don't pay Fair wages and your
conditions aren't great so they decided
they didn't want to [ __ ] do that
anymore
so the other part of it too is when you
look at these kids you also have to
realize that they themselves during that
period were figuring out exactly what
was going on right they were fair this
guy doesn't know what the [ __ ] he's
doing he's running a country into the
[ __ ] ground he doesn't care about the
lies of other people he says it's not my
responsibility he's you know trying to
uh to place blame on other people in
terms of the pandemic there's all these
things and these these kids these
students at the time they're like look
we have a lot to uh to offer to society
right now we're not just somebody who's
a little kid who then has to like uh
like as I get older then I get a voice
then I get a say these kids at that time
realize oh [ __ ] dude we can do so much
with what we have right now and we
should not be able to stand or take that
[ __ ] that somebody says and this is a
situation in which you would normally
say like oh the teacher says something
crazy maybe one kid
says something the rest is like oh shuck
I don't want to [ __ ] deal with that
because I'll get suspended or detention
or whatever or maybe somebody talks to
their parent
and none of the others laughing at him
yeah but none of the other students feel
like they can say something and now
these students are like [ __ ] that I'm
not dealing with this [ __ ] I know that I
have a certain View and that view is the
majority and that majority is that these
people are we are all equal we aren't
there's not a superior race or a
superior gender or that just because
you're a teacher makes you right and I
think that's the biggest lesson here is
that just because you're the person in
power in the situation doesn't make you
right we have to look at the facts of
what's going on and this guy's just a
racist and trying to trying to sugarcoat
it with wording like ethnocentric right
really it's I'm a [ __ ] racist right
and I believe white people are better
and that's what that guy's saying oh it
gets it gets better and the students
laugh at him even more because he
doubles and triples down on it listen to
this
the white is better than all let me
finish
you are what
you are a racist and you're like you're
racing everybody's a racist at that
level
I'll put your phone up
yeah I don't think I got respect for him
no more bro
uh oh what's the best the best part
about it not only that they laugh at him
that these kids are so are I have
educated themselves like you said
through the pandemic and what these
people have been yelling and screaming
because
the guy the guy thinks that he's on the
side of and the majority in this country
because that's the loudest of the loud
right yeah the white Christian
nationalists are so [ __ ] loud that
he's like I'm the majority and I could
tell these kids what to believe and what
I think and blah blah and that's the
other thing too is I I watch this
comment a lot
um they say [ __ ] like well he's not
allowed to have an opinion he is he is
allowed to have that opinion and let me
tell you something when you're a teacher
at a school and you are willing to say
that opinion that you are allowed to
have in front of in front of black
students when they laugh at you and when
they challenge you you get so upset that
they have a phone out that they're gonna
record you doing it
you are going to pay heavy consequences
for that opinion that you have yeah
really heavy now you could have just you
could have remain silent you're right to
remain silent and shut the [ __ ] up and
you could have went on about your day
and you could have just held those those
deep-seated racist beliefs inside of you
and just crawl back underneath your
[ __ ] rock but no you think you're the
majority and these kids I mean not only
did they laugh at him when he when they
gave just a little bit of push back here
just a little bit of bush back he
[ __ ] folded like a God damn tent oh
yeah and the other thing the other thing
that I think is is a very powerful to
see here is a lot of those students are
from the bipod Community right right and
so these kids again during the pandemic
what did we have happen we'd realized
that you know black indigenous Asian is
Hispanic like these lives do matter it's
not just White lives right and white
lives are the only thing that matters
because they're the deciding factor it's
that during this time there were people
within my own Community the Latino
Community the black community the Asian
Community all of these communities that
uh that realized oh [ __ ]
people actually care about us people
actually it's not it's not just a
minority of white people saying that we
don't matter and that we're the butt of
the joke right and that They Don't Care
About Us
but actually there is a monsoon of
people that that storm or March the
streets and and actually advocate for
our rights that we have actual equal
rights right and like you know black
lives don't matter or like all lives
don't matter
until a black lives matter and that's
the thing to realize and these students
who are from the bipod Community realize
during that time like oh [ __ ] we're not
just we're not alone it's not just our
thoughts of like man I I feel like I
belong and I feel like I should be
respected but nobody respects me you
have millions of people across the
country and across the world during this
time that corralled together and
actually supported
these people who are not white right and
yes the kids are all right like MJ says
the kids are all right these kids are
[ __ ] pushing and challenging the
status quo which is the white dude or
certain you know Republicans in power
we've got gen Z
a house uh candidate or now
um yeah from Florida from Florida that
has you know has been elected right yeah
he was posting that he this morning he's
he was uh it was early in the morning it
was still dark but the the Dome of the
capital was lit up on the outside and he
was standing outside and he said you
know it's starting to hit me I think is
I believe is what he was tweeting right
but I I want to say something here
because
um I think a lot of people fail to to
see this because I've been called a race
Trader and all kinds of [ __ ] [ __ ]
because I come I come from a very rural
racist part of the country it's Trump
country but let me tell you something
when it is it is imperative that white
folks white people push back against
this idea that this dummy had and the
reason why it's it's super important is
because what Gabe is saying is we give
space we're by Bach people people of
color and people of different religions
different backgrounds different cultures
we give them that space us as white
people when we allow them to show their
diversity when we allow allow them to
have that opportunity to laugh at this
[ __ ] right when we say no it is
not all right for a white person to say
this to children in a school it gives
those children the ability to laugh at
him and to challenge him not to not to
get violent not to get crazy not to
start throwing punches they literally
laughed in his face because there is
that space and and white white people
have to open that space we must take
away our privilege from ourselves it is
the only way for equality and Equity is
to is to just completely kill this idea
that we need white privilege for some
reason because that's what that guy is
holding on to this old [ __ ] notion
that he's Superior because he's white
and he has special rights and special
privileges because of it and and it's
everyone knows it that's what he's
saying he's saying everyone knows it
even you little black kid even you know
that I'm superior d down inside of you I
have these special privileges and when
they challenged him he [ __ ] folded he
said put your phone away because he knew
he was in trouble because they didn't
get violent they didn't get crazy they
all they did was laughing him mock him
number one that is important but then
they just pushed back just a little bit
and said defend your racism defend it
defend it you old [ __ ] ball sack
defend it in front of us and he couldn't
he couldn't do it because they can't
because there isn't a good defense right
well even there was there was one kid
who the kid who was standing up and then
sat down if you listen to what he said
his commentary's like man he's like I
didn't know if you're racist before but
now I definitely know and he sits down
and then the other I mean the other kids
were really pushing the fact that they
were like you're [ __ ] racist man like
what did you say you admitted that
you're racist you believe that white
people are better okay that's what he's
like no I I didn't say that I I did not
say that and it's like well then what
did you say right well speaking of um
speaking of bigoted white people the
former vice president United States and
fly holder
um is uh rolling out a book and I I
actually believe that Mike Pence was
betting on um these Trump candidates to
lose here just by some of the interviews
uh the clips from the interviews yeah
well it's always easier to you know come
out 2020 hindsight and say those things
as opposed to when the the biggest thing
he said was earlier this year which is
he was at a federal Society event and he
was like no the election wasn't stolen
or Donald Trump is wrong and that was
the most he said that was the most he
said from January 6th even though we
found out during the committee exactly
what was going on that was the most he
said which was earlier this year I think
it was March or February time
and he said uh
uh Donald Trump is wrong and the
election wasn't stolen and so on and so
forth but now you've got this
and I like cool he's speaking out
against Trump and Trust trumpism
whatever whatever you know I I don't
[ __ ] care yeah exactly because at the
end of the day if you really did believe
those two years too late you
[ __ ] you would have said those
things at the time if you really believe
like you're [ __ ] they wanted to
[ __ ] hang you man they they built
they built the Goddamn Gallows for you
they designed it they built it they
broke it down they transported it to DC
then they rebuilt it and then we're
chanting hang Mike Pence and during that
whole time he's like duh these guys
they're not so bad like they want to do
it here's the thing though that this is
gonna reveal is this [ __ ] held
all this in for two years and his
[ __ ] family his kids were standing
next to him and they were there with him
they were gonna kill him and kill his
children and he it took him two years to
come out I mean [ __ ] Donald Trump
calls Ted Cruz's wife ugly and Cruz puts
on his Cheeto dust knee pads and Mike
Pence had his life threatened by Donald
Trump because he tweeted him and his
lunch family are is him and his family's
lives were in danger and this
[ __ ] is just now saying
something now that Trump is down and
he's going to be indicted he's he's
going to likely Mount the campaign
that's going to be a losing campaign in
a primary IOP wins but I think he's
going to lose he'll probably have to
drop out because he won't be able to
gain a [ __ ] not a cent but this
[ __ ] here trying to sell a book
we talked about this before trying to
sell a book [ __ ] you Mike Pence and this
is the thing everyone shouldn't go oh
Mike Pence is a hero he's saying the
truth yeah but this has been the truth
for a long time he's [ __ ] Trump he's
[ __ ] trumpism he's just now finding
it convenient for him to walk away from
it like Josh Hawley ran away from the
supporters on January 6. let's not
forget that and let's tie this son of a
[ __ ] to Trump forever let's listen
members were barricaded inside the house
chamber
and in the middle of it all
you can see that the president has
tweeted
2 24 PM the president tweets Mike Pence
didn't have the courage to do what
should have been done
it angered me
but I turned to my daughter who was
standing nearby
and I said it doesn't take courage to
break the law
it takes courage to uphold the law I
mean the president's words were Reckless
it's clear he decided to be part of the
problem
it took you two years to muster the
Kurds to say that [ __ ] in front of a
camera you piece of [ __ ] garbage you
love Trump you continue to love Trump
you continue to Hitch to his wagon even
after he threatened to kill you and put
you and your daughter who was standing
next to you lives in danger you dumb
[ __ ] I I I'm look I I'm not a
betting man yeah but I would put money
on the fact that Mike Pence never said
that [ __ ]
no I'm gonna go with Mike Pence uh for
uh you know what I'll go for a thousand
here what is things that never happened
and uh or or I'll go for the category of
what is or or things that never happened
for a thousand and it is what is Mike
Pence sane
that exact line he never said [ __ ] he
might have actually talked to his
daughter on that day uh but I doubt he
ever said anything like that because I
would have to say two years two years
that he waited to actually I mean you
got to keep in mind he was trying to
figure out what to say and how to handle
January 6 as it was going down right he
had to confer with other people to
realize oh should I say something should
I not say something like how do I act on
January 6th what do I do because right
now I seem to be the only one who's
holding this [ __ ] together outside of
Nancy Pelosi who's actually trying to
get military assistance are you calling
Mike Pence a liar I think you're going
my Ben's life I'm calling him I'm
calling him a coward and I'm calling him
a liar I'm calling him a liar and a
coward
speaking of liars and cowards you gotta
see this have you seen this someone
unearth this ad I think Patriot takes
post to this no Ron DeSantis this is
[ __ ] real this is not a deep fake
this is this is a hundred percent real
watch this [ __ ] everyone knows my
husband Ron DeSantis is endorsed by
President Trump but he's also an amazing
dad Ron loves playing with the kids
build the wall he reads stories then Mr
Trump said you're fired I love that part
he's teaching Madison to talk make
America great again people say Ron's all
Trump but he is so much more big league
so good I just thought you should know
Ron DeSantis for governor
what the [ __ ]
listen listen that started that started
honestly the music the way it started
reminded me of like a sitcom like it was
like a jokey like oh it's gonna be
[ __ ] you know oh my God this is great
I I think we should you should
absolutely not replay this 32nd and
whenever whenever there's a wedge to be
drawn and this again this is what I've
been saying today and I will continue to
say it we we cannot let them run away
from trumpism [ __ ] them they owned it
they owned it and they lost and just
because they lost does not mean they get
to walk away from it [ __ ] that [ __ ] if
they thought it was such a winning
strategy and that's what they wanted to
press on the rest of us we should make
it known that those [ __ ] did
until they retire from politics and go
crawl back underneath their [ __ ]
rocks we tie them to this every single
day every single minute [ __ ] them Rhonda
Santos is not gonna walk away from Trump
you piece of [ __ ] not not the fake ass
suit the [ __ ] shoes the haircut the
hand gestures the [ __ ] The Voice
pattern you [ __ ] and this
commercial where he is absolutely
indoctrinating and grooming his children
which is hilarious that they [ __ ]
call us groomers and even in a
commercial he's joking that he's
grooming his children this is [ __ ]
weird it's [ __ ] gross and Ronda
Santas you own this [ __ ] now and
forever [ __ ] I'm gonna make you
own it you piece of [ __ ] I don't know I
think that's um what we should do
and what do you think
I no there is no way for there is no way
getting uh like away from this okay one
this whole ad is [ __ ] cringe okay
you're and that's what I thought I
thought it was put together great and
that's what Trump said you're fired I
love that part
and it's like okay uh let's just let's
just call what it is okay that's uh very
cultist right I know Ronnie is Donny's
baby bag [ __ ] is that from 2018 I have
no idea I mean I have no idea I don't
know but it's a real commercial what
does it matter where it's from I mean
we're gonna no I wanna I wanna
understand the timeline only because the
way in which Trump pushed to say like oh
yeah I went down and I sent FBI agents
and U.S attorneys to go help uh Ron
DeSantis and and uh and Rick Scott win
their election so part of me is like oh
yeah maybe are these tied together I
have no idea what I look at it and I say
uh Rhonda Sanchez is a [ __ ]
cuckoo Cruz and all these other people
like they were they were willing to
speak out against Trump when it was like
primary time and then as soon as he got
the nomination they're all like oh
yeah well you know here's the thing
is that even more Rhonda Santos is a
cuck his wife is the one narrating it
which is even better on the on the cuck
thing um I want to go to a different
governor's race this is uh Josh Shapiro
he's going to be the Pennsylvania
Governor he's going to make sure that
that swing state is secured for
democracy in other words whatever
decision that Pennsylvania would make in
the 2024 presidential election Josh
Shapiro is going to stand by that
decision
um which is you know following the rule
of law right trying to say hey you know
what my guy didn't win so I think he
should have won so that's who's going to
win but listen to Josh Shapiro here
Define mastriano and we can't forget
mastriana we have to tie these [ __ ] to
that [ __ ] uh Hitler wannabe but let's
listen to Shapiro here Define mastiano
and how that would have went your
Republican opponent Doug mastriano still
has not conceded the race five days
after CNN projected uh that you are the
winner are you still waiting for a phone
call what's your message to him
I mean who cares if he calls right you
know he doesn't get to pick the winner
the people pick the winner and in a
resounding way they made clear uh that
they wanted me to lead this Commonwealth
forward we had an historic win more
votes than any gubernatorial candidate
in history so I could care less if the
guy calls me what matters is the people
chose me and I look forward to getting
to work for them in January oh boy
stuffed him in a [ __ ] Locker like
literally like man I don't give a [ __ ]
if you call me and you can see I could
care less it doesn't make a [ __ ] tell
means worth of difference rather you
concede if I'm Governor or not it really
doesn't [ __ ] matter it couldn't
matter less yeah again it literally I
don't give a [ __ ] what he says I know I
won and the people said you won and uh
we did the election how we do the
elections and you can go
[ __ ] yourself yes that's mastriano
that's what I mean right beautiful way
to put it um one last thing I want to
point this out um again when we're
talking about wedges to draw here's a
wedge you can draw between the Cheeto
dust kiwin honor and Mitch McConnell
um he's really trying to plus press the
blame on this on anyone but himself
because he realizes that he has a
DeSantis problem right because he can't
it's hard for him to attack DeSantis he
figured that out over the weekend and in
the end of last week
um but so now he's on Full Assault and a
racist assault believe it or not on
Mitch McConnell because Mitch
McConnell's wife is is of Chinese
descent so he's being full on racist
here and trying to make well you saw the
one you saw the The Glenn young yeah
young pin yeah and yeah yeah he's like
funny how that the way it sounds like
that it's like no one ever thought that
no nobody no one ever thought that until
you decided to say racist ass pointed it
out which uh well um Larry Hogan the
former Governor Maryland pointed out on
Sunday he pointed out even if it was
young Ken it wouldn't be of Chinese
descent they would be of Korean descent
he's a dumb it's just another example of
trump being a dumb racist right here but
here's what here's what the Cheeto does
q anoner posted over the weekend about
Mitch McConnell and how it's his fault
this is great this is exactly what we
want folks like a lot of people like oh
he's deranged yes we know and that they
are all deranged he's their leader
that's the point so he this is what the
Cheeto does q and I are post on fraud
social it's Mitch McConnell's fault
spending money to defeat great
Republican candidates instead of backing
Blake Masters and others was a big
mistake it was a mistake Mitch McConnell
did that on purpose dummy giving four
trillion dollars to the radical left for
the green New Deal which is not the
green New Deal not infrastructure
meaning we like infrastructure money to
give away in Republican states but we
want to call it the green New Deal when
Democrats pass it he goes on was an even
bigger mistake so basically what Donald
Trump is saying is it was a huge mistake
for Americans to get investments in
their infrastructure are you listening
to him are you listening he's a [ __ ]
idiot this is why we want him to run uh
again he goes on he blew the midterms
blaming McConnell here and everyone
despises him and his otherwise lovely
wife or coco Chow is that what or
whatever he's being [ __ ] racist there
yeah the point is this the point is this
well it's a lane it's a lane show isn't
it is her full name yes Elaine challenge
right but the Coco Chow is a racist he
calls her that [ __ ] all the time this
isn't the first time he said it he said
it another true story posts and he's
saying he's pointing out that she's a CH
that she's Chinese like doesn't [ __ ]
matter like but this you know like this
guy again this is a prime example of
when when anyone in Maga or a republican
you know [ __ ] I'll just group them all
together when any Republican right
doesn't have an actual argument or or or
a defense for something
what they do is they oh you know what
I'm gonna now make a straw man argument
or an animal
right you're gonna do something
you want wieners on books and schools
it's the same thing they do not have an
actual thing to retort so then what they
say is oh racist term uh you're a
groomer you're a pedo you're this you're
that because you know Hey look it's
clearly you have your own issues and
you're trying to figure out what those
feelings are that you have and maybe you
are someone who is subject to those
things like maybe you're a pedophile
maybe you're a groomer it just seems
weird that that's your instant reaction
right to put on someone else right when
that wasn't even a topic of conversation
right well the other thing I'll point
out here is that when he says Mitch
McConnell's fault Mitch McConnell
intentionally done this to Trump because
Mitch McConnell did not want Trump to
have the Senate and what I mean by that
is he didn't want a bunch of [ __ ]
Trump candidates voting him out as
leader Mitch McConnell only cares about
one thing only one his power his power
Mitch McConnell's power he doesn't give
a [ __ ] about Trump's power he didn't
give a [ __ ] about anyone else's power
Mitch McConnell only cares about his
power and if Trump got his candidates if
he had odds Herschel Walker Blake
Masters
um JD Vance and the rest of them in the
Senate Mitch McConnell would have had a
caucus a trump caucus against him and he
would have lost his leadership rather in
the minority or the majority he didn't
give a [ __ ] he just wants to be the
leader that's all he wants because then
he controls money and that is why he
[ __ ] stuck money where where he knew
he could win Mitch McConnell Republicans
to keep himself in power that's why he
pulled money away from Masters is
because Blake Masters was gonna campaign
against McConnell the other thing too is
it's really funny that this [ __ ] [ __ ]
box grips off every single one of his
supporters who liked and reposted this
stupid thing and didn't give a [ __ ]
nickel not a [ __ ] nickel of that
money to those candidates that is
hilarious that he's saying Mitch
McConnell should have gave more money to
candidates when that [ __ ] didn't
give a dime to candidates right we
should point that out and we should
[ __ ]
there is there so I I will be doing a
what was that on this uh probably not
this next one but the following one will
probably be about how Trump is stealing
your money right and not not the people
who man fake Gabe obviously and yeah
they gave gambling yeah for sure fake
game has definitely you know uh
refinances how your home is taking a
second mortgage you know Soldier loans
and everything else just the [ __ ]
yeah just to give his money
but what um what I will be doing it on
is the fact that Trump during the 2020
midterms all right he sent out a text
that said
um actually I just I was just looking at
the other day
um this is literally what the text says
this is this is the campaign the
grifting text messages yeah yeah so this
one okay so there was a text message I
got on Friday from Trump's campaign and
it said press Trump we must save Georgia
from the Dems we've activated we've
activated a 1200 offer for one hour to
put America first step up and then the
Lincoln or whatever [ __ ] doesn't exist
at all yeah okay okay also again
they're they're making up numbers so you
can't like he would have to double down
on
uh on that percentage he would have to
find and he would have to find a way to
match that like if you're saying there's
a matching program you you donate then
we match it to our own program our own
campaign that's [ __ ] dumb but that
text message that said we must you know
uh defeat Dems to keep Georgia is the
exact same [ __ ] message that he sent
out in 2020
so when Georgia went and two runoff
seats right uh he sent a text message
that was used to grift off of the runoff
campaign the Georgia runoffs okay so he
sent that text he sent a ton of text ton
of texts sent him all the time and was
like hey it's the greatest text the best
textbook it was it was it was amazing
they were like send me the money uh he
gripped it off the backs of the Georgia
runoffs and he said give me money give
me money give me money give me money and
people gave money
he did not and I know this for a fact
because I've literally gone to the
financial records of his save America
pack he did not spend a [ __ ] penny on
the Georgia runoff even though he said
give me money and I'm gonna make them
win I'm gonna help them win we're gonna
make America great again Friday I get a
text message that same [ __ ] message
because we really are in a Deja Vu
situation we've got another runoff in
Georgia for Warnock versus Herschel
Walker
and now Trump is trying to grift off of
the runoffs again he will not give any
money no he said he was raising money
for the save America pack to go for the
midterms I don't know many candidates
that he actually gave money to
this is another moment where he has a
Super PAC or a save America pack and
he's using it for his own
interest his own game to pay off his
bills to pay off this to pay off that
he's got loans he's got debts he's
paying them off with their money are you
so sorry fake Gabe are you saying that
that Trump in the in the message IG or
the post that I just put up where he
said it's Mitch McConnell's fault he's
projecting is that what you're saying I
think that's what you're saying because
he's always projecting
folks it's been two long hours and it's
already over I can't even believe that
it's been two hours we had Dr Rachel
bittickoffer on today fantastic I hope
we have her back next week Gabe Sanchez
um this week Bo there's bound to be
plenty of boneheads enjoying bone end of
the week
um and I look forward to what was that
um with Gabe Sanchez do you got a
Twitter account with what was that too
yeah and once you go follow it that's in
your bio right it's in your bio and I
actually I just released I knew what was
that yesterday yeah so everyone go check
out uh Gabe Sanchez's uh Twitter page go
follow what was that Twitter page and
you can see that link there
um we'll try to retweet it and and get
that out maybe we'll play the what was
that tomorrow tomorrow is Tuesday no
that means it's Taco Tuesday it's Texas
Paul Tuesday and it's [ __ ] them Tuesday
because [ __ ] them you're the best
audience in the world thanks for joining
us don't forget to come back every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific for
two full hours on YouTube Twitter twitch
and simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page and our Facebook page of
course until tomorrow same time same
place Surf's Up [ __ ] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon